e
[Musique]
petite préfecture mais non feinte
atteint
[Musique]
ce qu'il y a
en voyeur
à montmagny solberg salomon kalou
essayez la patate a à bbb
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
25000 ses peluches 26000 ses peluches
25000 ses peluches 28000 c'est plus ça
tu n'as tu ne sais plus
mais j'ai mis en scène dans 5 minutes
jouées dans ma vie andré dulin ça c'est
c'est juste un souvenir du temps
non mais papa t'es sérieux quoi ils
regardent en teinte rouge mais il ya
quatre coups de la ccsa et ont demandé
d'acheter un stylo bleu d'acheter ainsi
rouge d'acheter s loverde acheté au noir
moi je t'ai pris un silo quatre couleurs
et toutes les couleurs il ya même pas du
globe monfils n'a pas besoin de gomme
pas été trop intelligent on doit pas
rater